eh bien faites vous vacciner puisque
vous avez l'air de trouver ça très bien
maintenant voyez pas que moi je sois
prudent et que je dise que l'union
européenne qui passent des contrats pour
acheter des millions de vaccins sans
savoir ce qu'il ya dedans sinon ça me
rassure pas et si je devais résumer cela
les phrases ceci très ce vieux dicton
populaire qui dit quand on veut tuer son
chien on dit qu'il a la rage
le paradoxe dans le pays de pasteur qui
a lui-même inventé le vaccin contre la
rage
de toute façon le vaccin pour l'instant
est destinée essentiellement à prévenir
la maladie grave et donc ce sont les
personnes à risque que nous voulons
vacciner donc prenez votre temps de
réfléchir vous allez voir ce tout va
bien se passer
nous expliquerons nous rassurons nous
accompagnerons et surtout nous
protégerons macro couronnes environ je
crois qu'une dépêche de l'elysée vient
d'annoncer que le président la
république avait lui-même été
diagnostiqué positif au cours aux
navires us
il va s'isoler pendant sept jours à
l'elysée à l'isolément également son
épouse brigitte 67 ans il faut qu'il
évite de croiser la première dame du
coup je cherche à la gamme devrait
éviter ce genre de plaisir
vous êtes humoriste mais je crois que je
vais éviter de retourner dans les palais
nationaux c'est dangereux oui oui c'est
dangereux
hier soir un autre dîner se tient dans
la salle des fêtes de l'elysée cette
fois le chef de l'état réunit une
dizaine de ses proches collaborateurs à
sa droite le secrétaire général de
l'elysée alexis colère à sa gauche
richard ferrand président de l'assemblée
nationale tous deux placés depuis ce
matin à l'isolément si nous sommes
malades main c'est parce qu'à un moment
donné nous n'aurons pas fait aussi
attention que nécessaire soit parce que
quand on tombe mal plus nécessairement
notre faute nous pas une question de
foot peut se poser la question
ces dîners de serre pas si il était
absolument nécessaire vous si c'était
pas une prise de risque inutile que de
le prétendre à tomber nationale disait à
juste titre c'est que nous devons être
collectivement bilan en aucun cas on ne
peut incriminer une personne qui serait
contaminée par le cos vide d'avoir
manqué de vigilance
le dîner qui a eu lieu hier soir le
déjeuner de travail qui a rassemblé les
présidents de groupe prévoyait des
distances de plusieurs mètres entre
chaque convive
et donc nous avons des micros pour cela
et et il est d'ailleurs arrivé ces
derniers mois que des membres du
gouvernement soient testés positifs ou
soit cas contacts doivent s'isoler
ce qui n'a jamais entravé le
fonctionnement du gouvernement qui se
poursuivent donc selon son agenda prévu
et malgré les contraintes liées aux
moments pendant le truchement de cette
vision de nos règles d'engagement qui au
sein de l'état peut s'inquiéter d'une
éventuelle contamination après avoir vu
emmanuel macron le premier ministre jean
castex d'abord il se mette à l'écart
pendant sept jours
son test pcr réalisé ce matin est
négatif il y à l'elysée que ce qui se
passe dans chaque endroit où des
personnes sont positives au coronavirus
c'est à dire la recherche de cas
contacts éventuels pour éviter qu'il y
ait des chaînes de transmission des
chaînes de contamination il y a dans ce
pays un problème inhérent au secret
professionnel des avocats et je compte
le régler
nous marquons ensemble le début d'une
nouvelle étape de la construction
européenne chef de l'état en
l'occurrence n'a pas été manifestement
contaminés au cours d'un déjeuner ou
d'un dîner à l'elysée mais
vraisemblablement d'après ce qu'on
entend en tout cas possiblement lors
d'un conseil européen il ya quelques
jours quatre ou cinq jours à bruxelles
avec des chefs d'état merci monsieur le
député lassalle d'une europe qui dispose
désormais donc et ben li ion nicolas
sarkozy une conversation entre un avocat
et son client doit rester entièrement
secrète dans tous les cas de figure
aurait vu un excellent juge de renom
sans doute par ci s'ils en sont là c'est
pour faire respecter son droit
[Applaudissements]